du haut de son hlm philippe regarder
mûrir ses tomates au pied de son
immeuble 23 jardins familiaux qui ont
poussé en même temps que cette cité de
colombes avec l'autoroute il y a trente
ans
là nous avons le jardin d'art traité ici
d'un agent ds de france et le jardin
suivant c'est le mien mais il y en a
encore là je suis chauffeur d'autobus
alors je passe te 7 8 heures dans le bus
à conduire et puis j'avais pas tellement
de loisirs extérieurs de sport et comme
j'aime bien manger ce qui est bien vient
de la terre
j'ai cherché à avoir un jardin philippe
et de cette nouvelle génération de
jardiniers actifs urbains et très peu
expérimentés son retour à la terre à
commencer par un bon plan tâche c'est
mes collègues à tous les gens qui sont
ici qui sont venus et qui m'ont qui
m'ont aidé et m'ont montré même le plus
rudimentaire des choses pour planter un
shu c'était tout ça je me souviens avoir
fait avoir planté comment dire des
plants de salades tous ensemble en
pensant ça ne faisait qu'une salade et
là ils ont bien rigolé et j'en rigole
encore
philippe est quand même devenu délégué
de la fédération des jardins familiaux
dans les hauts-de-seine
après une phase de disparition les
jardins ont été recensés et classé
espèce protégée depuis cette année c'est
un des aspects de la politique de la
ville dans le val de marne
le conseil général est allé encore plus
loin il a créé 85 jardin il ya cinq ans
dans ce bar de villejuif les abris sont
signées de l'architecte internationale
renzo piano et les clôtures sont
fournies par le département
ici au milieu des promeneurs entre les
plans de carottes et de haricots on
cultive avant tout la convivialité pas
toujours respectée surtout le soir la
nuit qu disons le parc n'est pas fermée
ce qui fait qu'à des bandes de jeunes
qui prennent et il ya des foyers des
dégâts qui est occasionnée il y à du
petit vandalisent comme on en trouve
parfois dans les parcs et ça reste tout
à fait limité
et effectivement le parc c'est un parc
ouvert au public
et je crois que ce qui est important
c'est les contacts aujourd'hui qui se
noue entre le promeneur et puis le
jardinier qui s'adonne à son passe temps
favori
il y eu de succès ici les parcelles ne
change presque plus de locataires et les
listes d'attentes sont très longues
comme partout en ile de france il faut
attendre un à deux ans
pourquoi c'est le chapeau du jardinier
des villes